- Billy, come on.
- [Offscreen] Okay, wait for it.
- Come on.
- Wait for it.
(industrial music)
Oh, okay, fine.
Hey! Reset.
- Come on!
- Are you ready
for Spring Break?
(megaphone feedback)
Spring Break, Spring Break.
Daytona Beach! Basketball.
- Basketball?
- Sports, sports!
Beach sports, water sports.
Oh, shake 'em up, shake 'em up.
Cocktail, Tom Cruise!
Shake 'em up, shake 'em up.
Knock, knock. Who's there?
Coconuts, shake
it up a two times.
Shake it up!
(beer can cracks open)
There's not much as I thought,
it was supposed to ...
Whoa, foam party!
Surfs up, whoo!
Gotta stay on the
board, my boogie board!
Whoa, whip curl, whoa!
Wipe out!
- Stop.
I never though I would say this,
but can we not drink and
cand we do your chores?
- What is happening
to you, Jean?
(camera click)
(suspenseful music effect)
(both scream)
(camera clicks)
- Oh, guys, I'm sorry.
- Richie, why are you
taking pictures of us?
- Probably for his tug-time.
- I'm not taking
pics of you guys.
I'm using my Spring
Break to photograph
the theater for the
school newspaper.
(camera clicks)
- What?
- And I don't masturbate.
Never got into it.
- Oh (bleep.)
(camera clicks)
- Bye.
- He is the definition
of an enigma!
- It's way too loud.
- Remember that band? Enigma.
- No.
- Okay.
- I don't know what that is.
(camera clicks)
(suspenseful music)
- Richie, is that you?
(heavy breathing)
- Let's go, let's
get out of here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why are you taking that?
- I wasn't.